the doctors stuck in the Pandorica Amy
might be dead and breweries are rolling
with a gun inside his hand seems like
things aren't going as planned rivers in
the TARDIS the TARDIS is on fire she's
feeling the heat don't repeat your
acquire someone she can trust someone
with a bowtie but he's been locked up
and left to die oh my god what will they
do it seems impossible to get through my
mind is blown Abed yours is do well I
guess this is doctor do
Rory's quite distressed and he starts to
song when the doctor appears with a mop
get me out of the Pandorica would you
not in the Pandorica yes I am well yes I
was it's complicated but I won't explain
it now because they need to zip it into
a hazy fuzz that will explain why he
doesn't think it does oh my god I don't
have a clue these paradoxes are hard to
construe my mind is blown aback yours is
too well I guess this is Doctor Who it's
the Big Bang 292 review one I've just
now
my eyes time is gonna skew the universe
eyes - I'll try and explain to you the
Big Bang -
the Big Bang to the dr. Scott rivers
full text manipulator which needs to
meet Rory 2,000 years later when they
meet Amy after sleep in the box they
realize the sound is really the exploded
plug thought to say river from the
imitator star this one watch it back
can't help but point out the obvious
oh my god he's wearing a fez oh my god
he's wearing if there's oh my colleagues
worrying if there's oh my God he's
wearing a fez and the darling pops up
out of nowhere shows the doctor kills
and quite a ver it jumps back 12 minutes
to the stairs he's dead and everyone
despairs little do they know the doctor
lies his on stopping the universe's
demise Amy says her last goodbyes doctor
flies up into the skies the universes
back it's true but the doctor said his
final and you maybe he'll come back at
your members you it's the big bang - I
need to review what enough just a boom I
time has been running the universe has -
but Amy still worn out but
someone's missing all the questions who
would you remember something old
something new something borrowed
something and that's the big man - I
hope you did confuse you you've just had
the almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool